[Music]
um
i'm queer and i'm too scared to tell my
family
i grew up in a very religious household
and
i just was very terrified
honestly i know my mom's gonna watch
this
later on because she's with me but
this is a good way to tell you i guess
so
[Music]
i hope you accept me my secret is
i used to be in the sex work industry
um i was brought in by a friend
and an ex-boyfriend i never really
wanted to be in it but
they made it seem like it was such a
good idea it's empowering and
you will make a lot of money and it's so
easy you can do it from home and so when
i got into it you know it was
there's always something uncomfortable
about it i didn't really
enjoy it but i just went along with it
for the heck of it
fast forward i actually got out of it
and that was honestly all thanks to god
and i realized you know my testimony is
important to me to share because this
media this world today makes it
seem like this is an empowering thing
for us to do but
in reality we're giving up the most
sacred most special part of ourselves
for a couple dollars for someone else's
pleasure for some unknown
man or some unknown person but that's
the sake most sacred part of us so
thank god i was able to come to jesus
come to christ after that
but whatever it is that can pull you out
of this industry
i highly encourage you to recognize your
own worth and find empowerment from
your true identity which is not your
[Music]
sexuality
my secret is i was raped three years ago
and i've never told the soul
[Music]
my secret is that sometimes i still
really struggle with feeling not good
enough
and i'm in a position where i
i teach a lot of people and i'm i'm
perceived as inspiring to
a lot of people and you know sometimes
it's still sometimes i still struggle
daily with just even feeling
good enough and showing up for myself
and
i don't know i guess i guess that
[Music]
my secret is that whenever i think about
starting to date someone
i don't want to date a stranger because
i'm not comfortable with that
but as soon as i get to know them and
they become my friends
i don't want to start dating my friend
so then i live in this paradox
and since i've been taught to value
romantic relationships
by society i always feel like i'm
missing out on something
because there's no way for me to meet
someone
naturally that i'd be comfortable with
dating
[Music]
my secret is that i'm pregnant and
nobody knows yet
[Music]
my secret is i hate my boss he is a
misogynistic
trump loving anti-massacre and i'm
quitting
tomorrow
[Music]
my secret is my boyfriend killed himself
in high school because of me
my secret is that i didn't spend more
time with my
grandfather who is dead in 2017
and he had six
grandchildren and he loved me the most
i didn't expect he will dance so quickly
and in the traditional chinese new year
eve
when he backed from hospital he said
that
he feel that this time he said goodbye
to everyone
to my mom to my father to all his other
grandchildren but he he never said
goodbye to me
the day after chinese traditional new
year he died
i don't know why he didn't say goodbye
to me
and one day i realized that maybe he
the reason he did said goodbye to me is
he don't want to say to me
hey don't wanna live left
me in the world i i feel so
so bad after realizing it if i can go
back time i will
definitely spend more time with my dear
grandfather
[Music]
okay yeah
my secret would be
i tell everything okay i have a secret
and my secret is
[Music]
dude i don't have i don't know
okay i'll say something um
my secret is
might sound lame my secret is i'm a
really good cook
and i like to tell anybody because if
you want then a lot of people want me to
make stuff for him
i'm just too lazy to make stuff for
people is that bad
i don't like to cook for nobody
so the first time that i ever got into a
car accident i actually hit a nun
and i was 16 and i'd just gotten my
driver's license
and i was going the speed limit and this
lady in front of me didn't use her turn
signal
and i i hit her she came out she yelled
at me and it was traumatizing but i got
over it eventually and then i found out
what had happened when my insurance
company told me that sister mary
was suing me because her neck hurt
really bad and she had not recovered
from the accident and i've never been
able to live it down
[Music]
all right come on you ready yeah all
right it's a secret i never told nobody
when i was about five i used to you know
know by phone i used to take a bath with
my sibling my sister
i peed in the tub and let her wash her
face in it
my secret is that i don't have a belly
button
a lot of people would think that that's
really interesting but i just have a
giant scar
and it's called an omphalocele and a lot
of people have no idea what that is i
barely know what it is and i was born
with it
[Music]
every time i go take out my dog for a
walk and it's raining a lot near my
house
and when she poops i don't pick it up
and i always tell my mom that i do
[Music]
my secret is i hate
when people talk to me while i'm eating
lunch
[Music]
oh this is sorry this is sorry i'm sorry
hold on
so i have a lot of secrets and i guess
it's all based on the same person which
is my ex-girlfriend
sometimes when i'm driving down the
freeway or highway or something like
that
i always turn to my ride and imagine my
ex sitting next to me
or when i'm in the shower i always
imagine her walking in
to the bathroom and i'm just wishing
that she was there
it's been five years since we broke up
and
i still love her the same way i loved
her when we first met
so if you're out there and you see this
i just want you to know that i truly
truly miss you and love you
[Music]
my secret is i believe we are on the
cusp of a new world and i'm an
agent of that change
so i chose to share the secret that i'm
reclaiming my sovereignty from the
mental health
industrial complex because i'm
just recently turned 36 and at 14
i was institutionalized in a psychiatric
facility
for around seven months and i
was started on around eight medic
psychiatric drugs
i was told that i would need those for
the rest of my life
if i wanted to have a shot at a normal
life
being in that system and being made to
believe that at such an impressionable
age like
it didn't allow opportunity in me to
know that i could heal
and that i could do that myself i'm now
like
nine months off after two years weaning
off all the psychiatric drugs i stayed
on for over two decades
and i'm starting to see that there's
like a whole other world that's
more vivid and colored in and that
there's so much possibility in that
world
so i think that things serve a place but
that
there's a lot more options that i was
never told of and
i feel that's a grave injustice and i
want that to stop for other people
[Music]
so if you want to hear me talk to boner
about that uh follow me
on my channel at dylan villainvision
[Music]
quick announcement if you didn't know
yet i recently launched my podcast it's
called hey stranger
and if you like these videos i think you
might like my podcast as well so it
means a lot if you gave it a chance i'll
have it linked in the description
so yeah i'm really excited to hear your
thoughts on it and yeah that's pretty
much it thank you guys for everything i
love you all
and i'll see you next week
[Music]